all right so if you guys saw my previous
three reviews for the Bourne films you
know I'm a huge fan of that series I was
excited for this movie I was looking
forward to it but the fact that Matt
Damon said that he thought the script
for was terrible it gave me a bad
thought the Bourne Legacy is the fourth
film in this series and I was thinking
what is this it's not a reboot it kind
of is a reboot it's not a prequel but it
kind of is what is this thing and I came
to the conclusion that it's a prequel
reboot spinoff it's the best I got this
film stars Jeremy Renner as an assassin
in the same program that Jason Bourne
was involved with his name is Aaron
cross and he is a superhuman I will snap
your neck and everything else in your
body in two seconds
machine yeah and Rachel vice plays this
scientist who works in this organization
as well Edward Norton is kind of like
the head of this area who's overseeing
all these events and when Jeremy Renner
and Rachel vies discovered the
corruption that's going on at this place
they flee and Edward Norton then sends
everyone with a gun
after them to kill them I'm a big fan of
the original three films and I loved
those movies actually they're some of my
favorite action movies they're movies
that are so good in the action genre
that so many films over the past ten
years have been trying to imitate them
very unsuccessfully and at first when I
heard about this especially since Matt
Damon and Paul Greengrass both didn't
want to be involved with the fourth
Bourne film after they saw where it was
going I was very very pessimistic about
it but then I thought the trailers and
they got Jeremy Renner who's a very
capable actor Edward Norton you know all
these good talents in there and I was
getting excited for it and this movie
definitely has good things about it
Jeremy Renner is a capable actor he's
good at what he does he's good with his
stunts he does a lot of stunts in this
movie I was very impressed Rachel vies
is also a very good actress she always
is very real in her roles and Edward
Norton I think is one of the best actors
we have working today and from the
trailers they were really promoting this
movie to be like this huge action movie
lots of fights lots of chases but I'm
gonna tell you a fact okay this is not
an opinion this is a fact this movie's
135 minutes long and I would say there's
probably about 10 full minutes of action
in this movie let me just put it this
way when I was walking out of the movie
a woman like blurred by me in a rage and
like stormed through the door and went I
wanted an action movie this was just
talkie talkie talkie there was no
accident in this movie and normally I
would kind of just like smirk at a
comment like that but she is
absolutely right what the critics are
saying is true there is an incredible
lack of action in this movie it is
mind-blowing how much action is actually
not in this movie if you saw the trailer
you saw almost every fight scene in this
movie I'm not kidding this is an
extremely dialogue heavy film and it's
not the best dialogue in the world it
really isn't like I talked to my friend
on the phone after the movie and he was
like am I an idiot or it's that one of
the most confusing movies of the year so
far I was like no dude I don't know what
the heck was going on in this movie I
saw the movie tonight and I honestly
don't understand the plot I mean I get
the plot points I get this is happening
how this is happening now and this is
happening now but why what is the
purpose you know what is this to have to
do with anything the characters in this
movie talk like we just understand
exactly what they're saying
automatically it's like the scriptwriter
is so into this script he's been writing
it for years and he understands every
little element of it but for a
first-time viewer you're like what in
the world is going on right now
so the extreme lack of action and the
dialogue being so wordy and heavy and
very difficult to understand really
clashes to make a kind of bland mediocre
movie unfortunately Jeremy Renner is a
great actor he's a capable actor but his
character is a superhero in this movie
I'm just he's a superhero
he has never challenged once in this
movie he barely even breaks a sweat he
never encounters one person in this
movie that he cannot take down with in a
second there is never one scene in this
movie in which you feel like crap the
hero might actually get hurt here he is
on top of things throughout every single
action scene in this movie all two or
three of them he's never challenged once
in this movie he's a superhero he is a
completely impervious person and so the
action is tensionless there is no
tension in the action and it's just cool
to look at that's it in the original
Bourne films when Bourne was fighting -
and he was getting his butt kicked like
on the ground he was just getting
pummeled you really felt like this this
guy's a human you know he can get hurt
like me I have tension I feel suspense
now none of that exists in this movie
poor Edward Norton is such a good actor
but he has absolutely nothing to do here
the trailer makes it seem like he's
gonna face off with Jeremy Renner in
fact there's a scene in the trailer that
is the biggest bait-and-switch cut edit
this isn't exactly how it is but we're
gonna make you think it's like this in
the trailer look at this clip from the
trailer of Edward Norton talking to
Jeremy Renner there was nothing that you
wouldn't do for this country you and the
strength to do what's necessary
yeah Edward Norton son actually talking
to Jeremy Renner in the movie he's
talking to a completely different
character in a completely different
location and they cut it together to
make it seem like those characters are
going to have scenes together they have
one scene together in the entire movie
and it's a flashback scene before any of
the stuff of this movie happened where
you remember the time he spent with him
in some war somewhere they set him up as
such a cool possibility for an
antagonist and he does nothing in this
movie except sit behind the computer
room and look at camera footage of
Jeremy Renner going places when the
action is there it looks convincing you
know it's not horribly filmed or
anything it's just there is no tension
to it at all and it just kind of goes by
and okay now we're gonna have another 40
minutes literally of just talking I
could not believe how boring this movie
actually was the film has good
intentions it's acted well it looks nice
but there's just nothing here compared
to the other films they shouldn't even
have the Bourne title in it it's just a
very bland and mediocre movie and being
harder on this movie that I normally
would for a movie like this like this
was a standalone movie I wouldn't be
this hard on it but since it is clearly
coming off as a giant cash grab with no
real importance to it at all I'm gonna
give the Bourne Legacy a/c it's coming
out in a few days once you guys do see
the movie I'm interested in knowing how
you feel about it thanks for watching
the review guys if you like this to
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]